Are you one of those media strategy people clicking through slides, scrolling spreadsheets? Yes? Good. This is for you. Because on Spotify, there's an audience that's different. Locked in. Loyal, invested. They're called fans. Fans don't just listen to music. They feel seen by it, like it belongs to them. So when your brand shows up on Spotify, that's who you're talking to. And you're right next to artists like me, Lizzo. So, are you ready to talk to fans? Spotify Advertising. You're among fans. Are you being watched by Bossware?
你是不是那种在幻灯片和电子表格之间点来点去的媒体策略人员？是的？很好。这个就是为你准备的。因为在 Spotify 上，有一群与众不同的受众。全神贯注。忠诚，投入。他们被称为粉丝。粉丝不只是听音乐。他们从音乐中感受到被理解，觉得音乐是他们的一部分。所以，当你的品牌出现在 Spotify 上时，这就是你在对话的对象。而且你就站在像我这样的艺术家旁边，比如 Lizzo。所以，你准备好与粉丝对话了吗？Spotify 广告。你置身于粉丝之中。你正在受到“老板软件”的监视吗？
If so, you're not alone. In recent years, an increasing number of employers have begun using electronic surveillance methods to keep tabs on their employees. From keystroke trackers and webcams that record remote workers every move, to video tools that look for signs of fatigue on truckers' faces, to devices that track the movement and location of warehouse workers, an increasing number of us across a wide range of jobs are being my own. monitored while we work. Employers say that the tools help improve productivity and in
如果是这样，你并不孤单。近年来，越来越多的雇主开始使用电子监控手段来监督员工。从记录远程工作者一举一动的击键追踪器和网络摄像头，到寻找卡车司机面部疲劳迹象的视频工具，再到追踪仓库工人运动和位置的设备，我们当中越来越多从事各种工作的人在工作时正受到监视。雇主表示，这些工具可以帮助提高生产力，在
some cases safety, but critics contend that monitoring invades workers' privacy and often does more harm than good. Today we're going to talk to a psychologist who studies workplace digital surveillance about how being watched changes workers' behavior, how common are these digital surveillance devices, and how are they being used in different industries?
某些情况下还能提高安全性，但批评人士认为，监控侵犯了员工的隐私，往往弊大于利。今天，我们将采访一位研究职场数字监控的心理学家，探讨被监视如何改变员工的行为、这些数字监控设备有多普遍，以及它们如何在不同行业中使用？
How has the rise of AI tools changed workplace surveillance? and what laws and regulations govern whether and how your employers can monitor you at work. Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. My guest today is Dr. Tara Barron, the John Richard Butler II, endowed professor at the School of Human Resources and Labor Relations at Michigan State University. She is an industrial organizational psychologist whose research focuses on the ethical, social, and psychological implications of workplace technologies, including electronic surveillance.
人工智能工具的崛起如何改变了职场监控？以及有哪些法律法规来规范雇主是否以及如何能在工作中监控你。欢迎收听《心理学谈话》（Speaking of Psychology），这是美国心理学协会（American Psychological Association）的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理学科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。我今天的嘉宾是密歇根州立大学（Michigan State University）人力资源与劳工关系学院（School of Human Resources and Labor Relations）的约翰·理查德·巴特勒二世（John Richard Butler II）讲席教授塔拉·巴伦（Dr. Tara Barron）博士。她是一位工业组织心理学家，其研究重点是职场技术（包括电子监控）的道德、社会和心理影响。
She's authored more than 100 academic journal articles and has written or edited four books. She's also a program director for the National Science Foundation, where she chaired the Future of Work Working Group and oversaw the Science of Organizations program. Dr. Barron, thank you for joining me today. Thank you so much for having me. How common are digital surveillance technologies and workplaces today? I mentioned a few examples in the introduction, but can you give us a fuller sense of the range of technologies and the way that they're being used? Yeah, those were great examples that you mentioned in your intro, and what we know is that these are becoming common in more and more occupations. I think just this morning, there was a news story about meta using this sort of technology.
她撰写了 100 多篇学术期刊文章，并编写或编辑了四本书。她还是美国国家科学基金会（National Science Foundation）的项目主任，在那里她主持了“未来工作工作组”（Future of Work Working Group），并负责监督“组织科学”（Science of Organizations）项目。巴伦博士，非常感谢您今天加入我们。非常感谢邀请我。当今数字监控技术在职场中有多普遍？我在引言中提到了几个例子，但你能否让我们对各种技术及其使用方式有更全面的了解？是的，你在引言中提到的那些是非常好的例子，我们所知道的是，这些技术在越来越多的职业中变得普遍。我想就在今天早上，还有一则关于 Meta 对其软件工程师使用这种技术的新闻报道。
for their software engineers. And you can think of automation and surveillance as going hand in hand, because in order to automate a job, you have to know a lot about it. And so there's an incentive to collect a lot of information from workers so that you can design these automation. So as the technology improves to automate more and more work, people are more and more attempted to use these tracking devices on their current workers. What are the reasons do companies and organizations give for doing this? I mean, what do they say they're trying to accomplish? And what do they do with the data they're collecting? Sure. So in many cases, I would say organizations don't know why they're collecting the data, but they do know that there's a sense that data is powerful and they should have a lot of it
你可以认为自动化和监控是密不可分的，因为为了使工作自动化，你必须对它有很多了解。因此，人们有动力从工人那里收集大量信息，以便你能够设计这些自动化系统。因此，随着技术不断改进以实现越来越多工作的自动化，人们越来越倾向于在现有工人身上使用这些追踪设备。公司和机构这样做的原因是什么？我的意思是，他们说他们想达到什么目的？他们如何处理收集到的数据？当然。所以很多时候，我想说组织并不知道他们为什么要收集这些数据，但他们确实意识到有一种感觉，即数据是强大的，他们应该拥有大量数据，
and they'll figure out what it all means later. So they collect anything they can collect without really having a question in mind that they're trying to answer. Beyond that, there's always an increasing drive for efficiency, and people believe that these tracking tools can identify areas that efficiency could be improved. Maybe you are tracking your drivers so that you can optimize the route that they take through a neighborhood, or maybe you are tracking the movements that people make throughout a warehouse, and you think you can shorten the route. So it can start from a fairly neutral place. Many companies take this way too far and end up creating really unsafe conditions as a result.
至于这一切意味着什么，他们以后再弄清楚。所以他们收集任何能收集到的东西，却没有真正带着他们试图解答的问题。除此之外，对效率的追求总是在不断增加，人们相信这些可以识别出可以提高效率的领域的追踪工具。也许你在追踪你的司机，以便你可以优化他们穿过某个街区的路线，或者你在追踪人们在整个仓库中的移动轨迹，并且你认为你可以缩短路线。所以它可以从一个相当中立的角度开始。许多公司把这一点做得过头了，结果导致了非常不安全的状况。
How do you mean? What kinds of unsafe conditions? Sure. Well, so what monitoring does is create a really clear incentive and a really strong signal about what kinds of things are important. So if I'm tracking how fast you drive, but not how safely you drive, then I'll pay more attention to speed. whether I make a full stop at a stop sign. So what you're doing when you're tracking these
你这话是什么意思？什么样的不安全状况？当然。嗯，所以监控所做的是创造了一个非常明确的激励机制，以及一个关于什么样的事情很重要的强烈信号。因此，如果我追踪你开得有多快，而不是你开得有多安全，那么我会更多地关注速度，而不是我在停车标志前是否完全停下来。所以，当你追踪这些
behaviors is you're shaping people's attention and you're creating a really strong motivation for them to optimize that metric at any cost. So that can mean taking shortcuts or doing things that are really unsafe or creating really unhelpful competition between people if you're trying to win some leaderboard. And all of those things are not really in the organization's best interest and end up costing more money over time. But it's a natural consequence of how we think about motivation. How else do people's behavior change when they know they're being watched at work and are the effects different for different types of jobs?
行为时，你实际上是在塑造人们的注意力，并为他们不惜一切代价优化该指标创造了强烈的动机。这意味着可能会走捷径，或者做一些非常不安全的事情，或者如果你试图赢得某种排行榜，就会在人们之间产生非常无益的竞争。所有这些事情其实都不符合组织的最大利益，随着时间的推移，最终会花费更多的钱。但这正是我们对动机的看法所带来的自然结果。当员工知道自己在工作中被监视时，他们的行为还会发生什么其他变化？对于不同类型的工作，这种影响是否有所不同？
Yeah, so the monitoring is definitely a source of distraction. And whether that harms your job performance is going to depend on the kind of job you're doing and how much it's important that you're paying really close attention to something. if you're a driver and some small part of your attention is not on the road because you're worried about what the camera can see, that's going to increase accidents, right? Because you need your full attention. If your job requires a lot of vigilance, so a common example of that would be a security screener at the airport who's watching the x-ray, like you really need to pay attention and not make mistakes. You want people to have their full attention available to them to do that job. And the, the, the, the, the, more cognitive effort a job takes, the more dangerous it is to potentially take away some of that, some of those resources. So my colleagues and I are currently working on a study of police officers who are monitored with their body cameras. And they need to have their full attention, obviously. The camera is on not just when they're on a call, but in many cases when they're in their car between
是的，所以监控绝对是一个分心来源。这是否会损害你的工作表现，将取决于你所从事的工作类型，以及你对某事保持高度专注有多重要。如果你是一名司机，而你的一小部分注意力不在路上，因为你在担心摄像头能看到什么，这会增加事故发生率，对吧？因为你需要全神贯注。如果你的工作需要高度的警惕性，一个常见的例子就是机场的安检人员，他正在查看 X 光机，你真的需要集中注意力，不能出错。你希望人们能够全神贯注地去完成这项工作。而且，一项工作需要的认知努力越多，分走其中一部分资源的潜在危险就越大。因此，我和我的同事目前正在开展一项关于佩戴随身摄像头的警察的研究。显然，他们需要全神贯注。摄像头不仅在他们接警时开启，在许多情况下，当他们在车里等待接警、
calls, taking a break. And what it means is that they can't, they can't do that decompression, that stress relief that they would ordinarily be doing in that time. So they're just at this really high, intense level of energy and adrenaline all the time because they don't have a chance to relax. Generally speaking, how do employees feel about being monitored? Do we know, do they hate it or do they understand there might be some good reasons? And are there differences when we're talking about white collar, blue collar, pink collar in terms of how people feel. Yeah, yeah. So if we think about the surveillance as a source of organizations exerting power over people,
休息时也会开启。这意味着他们无法进行通常在那段时间里会进行的减压、缓解压力的活动。因此，由于没有放松的机会，他们总是处于这种非常高强度、高度紧张的精力和肾上腺素水平中。总的来说，员工对被监控有什么感受？我们知道吗，他们讨厌监控，还是理解可能有某些充分的理由？当我们谈论白领、蓝领、粉领时，人们的感受是否存在差异？是的，是的。所以如果我们把监控看作是组织对人们施加权力的一种来源，
then the effects on you depend on how much power you have in that organization. So in some of our recent research, we were able to show that the people with the least power in the organizations are the most negatively affected by the surveillance, meaning it is being used to control them, to remove their autonomy, to remove their ability to use their judgment, to do their job, to punish them for things that they shouldn't be punished for, to really just control and micromanage them. But if you're in a job that has more power, say you're a surgeon, then that tracking is done for your safety, for your patient's safety. It might be used to give you feedback so that you can improve your job. But it's not being used in the same way to
那么它对你的影响取决于你在该组织中拥有多少权力。在我们最近的一些研究中，我们能够证明，组织中权力最小的人受监控的负面影响最大，这意味着监控被用来控制他们、剥夺他们的自主权、剥夺他们运用判断力来完成工作的能力、因不该受惩罚的事情而惩罚他们，以及真正地控制他们并对他们进行微观管理。但如果你从事的是权力更大的工作，比如你是一名外科医生，那么这种追踪是为了你的安全、为了你病人的安全。它可能会被用来为你提供反馈，以便你能改进工作。但它并没有被用来以同样的方式
to punish and control and second guess your judgment. But, I mean, speaking of surgeons, now that data belongs, say, to the hospital. So if the surgeon left an instrument in a person's body and the hospital has that information, I mean, they're not obligated to turn that over anybody, are they? No. Well, it's an interesting legal landscape. There's really not a lot of protections for workers in the U.S., but there's also not a lot of guidance in terms of who owns that data and how long they have to hold on to it and who they have to disclose.
惩罚、控制和质疑你的判断。但是，我的意思是，说到外科医生，现在这些数据属于医院了。因此，如果外科医生在病人体内遗留了手术器械，而医院掌握了这些信息，我的意思是，他们没有义务把这些交给任何人，对吧？不。嗯，这是一个有趣的法律格局。在美国，对工人的保护确实不多，但在谁拥有这些数据、他们必须保留多长时间以及必须向谁披露方面，也没有太多的指导。
Unless it overlaps with another area where we already have law, like FERPA or HIPAA would be two examples, where we already have rules about how to control patient data and student data in those two cases. But unless it falls into a category where we already have protections, their workers can be tracked for any reason under any circumstances and what the organization does, that data is really up to them. What about laws and regulations around this right now? I mean, our employers, there's certain things that they're allowed, I mean, you just made it sound like they can watch anything.
除非它与我们已经拥有法律的其他领域重叠，比如 FERPA 或 HIPAA 就是两个例子，在这两种情况下，我们已经有了关于如何控制患者数据和学生数据的规则。但是，除非它落入我们已经有保护措施的类别，否则工人在任何情况下都可以出于任何原因被追踪，而组织对这些数据采取什么行动真的完全取决于他们。目前围绕这方面的法律和法规情况如何？我的意思是，我们的雇主，有些事情是允许他们做的，我的意思是，你刚才听起来好像他们可以监视任何事情。
Are they obligated to tell you what they're doing? Right. So currently, no. There are a few states that have some requirements about transparency, meaning that that people are notified about what is being tracked, but there's no federal guidance on this issue. If you compare that to the EU or Canada or Australia, all of those places require disclosure of what is being monitored and also that only work-related behaviors are monitored. So you can't look at people's personal emails just because you can. You can't follow them with their company
他们有义务告诉你他们在做什么吗？是的。目前来看，没有。有几个州对透明度有一些要求，这意味着人们会被告知正在追踪什么，但在这个问题上没有联邦指导。如果你把它与欧盟、加拿大或澳大利亚进行比较，所有这些地方都要求披露正在监控的内容，并且只监控与工作相关的行为。所以你不能仅仅因为你可以就去查看人们的个人电子邮件。你不能用他们的公司设备通过 GPS 追踪他们。你不能做这些与工作无关的事情，但在美国联邦层面目前没有任何限制或保护。我们将进行短暂的休息。当我们回来时，我将与巴伦博士讨论人工智能如何改变职场监控，以及员工如何应对被监控的压力。在多伦多，每一次抵达都是一种宣言，而没有什么比这更能说明问题了。凯迪拉克 Optic 是 2025 年加拿大最畅销的豪华电动汽车。通过无缝的 33 英寸显示屏和身临其境的 19 扬声器 AKG 环绕声音响系统，找到你的节奏。这座城市需要灵活性，而 Optic 以精准度交付，让每一次驾驶都非同凡响。让我们选择凯迪拉克。在 Cadillac Canada.ca 了解更多信息。
device using their GPS. You can't do these things that are not job-related, but there are no restrictions or protections in the U.S. federally currently. We're going to take a short break. When we return, I'll talk with Dr. Barron about how AI is changing workplace monitoring and about how employees handle the stress of being monitored. In Toronto, every arrival is a statement, and nothing says it better than this. Cadillac Optic was the number one selling luxury EV in Canada for 2025. Find your rhythm across a seamless 33-inch display and an immersive 19-speaker AKG surround audio system. This city demands agility and optic delivers with precision to make every drive extraordinary. Let's take the Cadillac. Find out more at Cadillac Canada.ca.
豪华车销量声明基于标普全球移动公司（S&P Global Mobility）加拿大新车总注册量，适用于 2025 日历年凯迪拉克的豪华车定义。本集由欧莱雅集团（L'Oreal Group）为您呈现。美是一种强大的力量，能够激励我们。这就是为什么欧莱雅集团建立了一项以包容性为核心的业务，其 100% 的品牌都倡导多元化。在全球范围内，为 30 岁以下的人群提供 25,000 个专业机会，且 54% 的领导岗位由女性担任，
Luxury sales claim based on S&P Global Mobility Canadian New Vehicle Total Registrations for calendar year 2025 for the Cadillac definition of luxury. This episode is brought to you by L'Oreal Group. Beauty is a powerful force that moves us. That's why L'Oreal Group has built a business that is inclusive. at its heart with 100% of its brands championing diversity. With 25,000 professional opportunities for people under 30 worldwide and 54% of leading positions held by women,
多元化是一项优势，它帮助欧莱雅集团为所有人创造最好的美容产品。访问 laurel.com 了解更多信息。现在，我们都知道人们相当聪明，能够想出变通的办法。例如，我认识一个人，他发现自己可以在电脑的空格键上放一个重物，这样即使他没有工作，看起来也像在工作，事实上他去度假了。但不管怎样，作为员工，我们被允许做任何事情来阻止监控吗？这算是一把双刃剑吗？当然。所以，我很喜欢空格键放重物这个例子，因为这有助于我们非常清楚地看到，被监控的事情并不是
diversity is a strength that helps L'Oreal Group create the best beauty products for all people. Visit laurel.com to learn more. Now, we all know that people are pretty clever and that they can figure out workarounds. For example, I know someone who figured out that they could put a weight on the space bar of their computer, and it would look like they were working when they weren't, and in fact, they went on vacation. But anyway, are we as employees allowed to do anything to block surveillance? As it cut both ways. Sure. So I love that example of the space bar on the weight, because what it does is help us see very clearly that the things being monitored are not the things
对工作绩效最重要的事情。我在键盘上按了多少下按钮，并不是衡量我工作做得好坏的好标准。特别是对于许多远程工作者而言，他们的可用性图标正被用作了解其绩效的替代指标。比如在 Teams 上，如果你处于闲置状态，你的小图标可以从绿色变成黄色。人们对此感到担忧。他们担心看起来没有生产力。因此，你可以在网上买到一些设备，它们会一整天帮你在周围移动鼠标，这样你看起来就不会没有生产力了。对吧？但这是一个，它之所以有效，是因为人们在衡量错误的东西。比如，
that are most important to job performance. How many buttons I push on my keyboard is not a good measure of whether I'm doing my job well. And for many remote workers in particular, their availability icon is being used as a proxy to understand their performance. Like on teams, your little icon can turn from green to yellow if you're idle. And people worry about that. They worry about looking like they're not productive. And so there are devices you can buy online that will just move your mouse around for you all day so that you aren't looking unproductive. Right? But this is a, it's, it works because people are measuring the wrong things. Like,
他们在衡量那些无关紧要的事情。所以你能绕过它吗？嗯，当然，除非你被抓到，然后你可能会因此被解雇。但是，如果你是以正确的方式受到监控，也就是说，评估你实际上确实重要的绩效方面，那么绕过它的那些动机就真的不复存在了。鉴于这一切，监控变得越来越复杂了吗？我的意思是，人们是否正在使用人工智能等技术来观察那些真正产生影响的事情，而不是你是否在键盘上打字，而是你所产生的工作质量？是的，技术确实越来越复杂了，但这并不意味着它们现在必然在衡量重要的事情。这只是意味着它们可能在抓取更多
they're measuring things that don't matter. So can you work around it? Well, sure, unless you get caught, and then you can probably be fired for that. But, but if you are being monitored in the way that you should be, which is to say evaluating aspects of your performance that actually do matter, then those incentives to get around it don't really exist anymore. Given all that, is surveillance getting more sophisticated? I mean, are people using AI, for example, to look at things that really make a difference, not whether you're typing on your keyboard, but the quality of the work that you're producing? Yes, the technologies are getting more sophisticated, but no, that does not mean that they're necessarily measuring things that matter now. It's just that they're grabbing potentially more
附带的数据或更具侵入性的数据。因此，如果我追踪你的面部表情，并且我能弄清楚你可能正在表现出患病的迹象，然后我说，嗯，这个人不会有生产力。他们患有我可以通过面部识别检测出来的慢性病，然后解雇他们。我的意思是，这并没有因为更复杂而变得更好。因此，人们仍然必须仔细思考什么是工作以及应该如何评估工作。但诱惑往往只是利用这些技术来获取任何你能得到的信息，并在以后去理解它。这真的是一场危险的游戏。但现在这种监控对人们来说可以是完全不可见的。你可能不知道什么被捕获了、出于什么目的、谁有权访问它、他们用它做什么。他们不需要
incidental data or more invasive data. So if I'm tracking your facial expressions and I can figure out that maybe you're displaying signs of illness and then I say, well, this person is not going to be productive. They've got a chronic illness that I can detect with my facial recognition and fire them. I mean, that's not better because it's more sophisticated. So people still have to think carefully about what a job is and how it should be evaluated. But the temptation is just to use these technologies to grab any information you can and make sense of it later. And it's really a dangerous game. But now this surveillance can be completely invisible to people. You might not know what's being captured for what purpose, who has access to it, what they're doing with it. They're not required
告诉你，而且你也不一定会看到任何这方面的证据，除非你注意到你的朋友被解雇了，然后你开始，你知道的，开始怀疑和猜测。我不知道他们为什么被解雇。因此，人们肯定会对正在追踪的内容得出自己的结论，但这并不意味着他们是基于任何数据来这样做的。鉴于公司无法真正分析他们收集的所有这些数据，我们现在是不是就不用担心了？我的意思是，你知道，我只是在想，如果老大哥在看着他们，我们的听众应该有多担心？我认为这是一个公平的问题，有很多人会认为隐私已成为过去，我们在网上所做和所说的一切都将永远存在，我们无法真正控制这一点。而且我确实认为，隐私确实更难获得了。
to tell you and you wouldn't necessarily see any evidence of that unless you noticed that your friend got fired and you start, you know, you start wondering and speculating. I wonder why they get fired. And so people will certainly come to their own conclusions about what's being tracked, but it doesn't mean that they're doing that based on any data. Given that companies can't really analyze all this data that they're collecting, should we just not worry at this point? I mean, you know, I'm just wondering, you know, how concerned should our listeners be if Big Brother is watching them? I think that's a fair question, that there are plenty of people who would argue that privacy is a thing of the past, that everything we do and say online is there forever and that we can't really control that. And I do think it's true that privacy is much harder to attain.
我的意思是，现在街上可能有人戴着可以记录你的眼镜，并向你提供个人信息，而你无法对这种活动表示同意或不同意。因此，对隐私的威胁肯定是一波接一波，但这并不意味着我们不应该对此关切。我们当然仍然应该对我们在网上发布的内容保持深思熟虑，例如，或者我们在公司设备上写了什么，即使那是我们的个人电子邮件。我的意思是，我认为保持界限可能比以往任何时候都更加重要。并将其作为保护自己的一种方式严肃对待。对于那些正在被监控的员工，在应对压力以及保持对它可能如何影响他们的工作的认识方面，你还有其他建议吗？是的。如果在被监控中有什么好处的话，那就是可能会实时收到反馈，并利用这些反馈来提高你的工作表现，确保你的安全。我认为为了这个目的而接受它可能是有价值的。很多人都有这样一种自然的倾向，那就是当你的自由受到限制时，你会有通过维护自由来恢复平衡的需求感。在某些方面，这可能真的不符合你自己的最佳利益。那种我们可能会报复雇主的想法，对吧，比如，我要让你好看，因为你对进行了微观管理。
I mean, now there are maybe people walking down the street wearing glasses that are recording you and providing personal information to you and you have no way of providing consent or not consent. for that kind of activity. So there's certainly just an onslaught of threats to privacy, but I don't think that means we shouldn't care about it. We should certainly still be thoughtful about the kinds of things that we put online, for example, or what we write with our company device, even if it's our personal email. I mean, I think maintaining boundaries is maybe even more important than ever. And taking that seriously as a way of protecting yourself. Do you have any other advice for employees who are being monitored just in terms of handling the stress and staying aware of how it might affect their work? Yeah. To the extent that there's a benefit from being monitored, it would be about receiving feedback potentially in real time and using that to improve your performance to keep you safer. And I think adopting it for that purpose can potentially be valuable. there's a natural tendency that a lot of people have, which is that when your freedom is restricted, you have a sense of needing to fix the balance by asserting your freedom. And in some ways, that can just really not be in your own best interest. The idea that we might get our employers back, right, by like, I'm going to show you because you micromanage me.
现在我真的没有在帮助我自己的职业生涯。我这样做并没有在帮助我的同事。我只是在情绪化地行事。我认为我们可以抵制这种诱惑，但我同时也认为，推动对工人的保护真的非常重要。我的意思是，目前确实存在一个非常戏剧性的权力失衡。实现这一目标的途径不是让个人与老板争吵，而是努力争取联邦层面的保护。目前在这方面是否有你所了解的努力？
And now I'm not really helping my own career. I'm not helping my colleagues by doing that. I'm just sort of acting out emotionally. I think we can resist that temptation, but I also think it's really important to advance protections for workers. I mean, there is currently a really dramatic power imbalance. And the way to do that is not for individual people to get into fights with their bosses, but rather to try to achieve federal protections. And are there efforts on that front right now that you're aware of?
有的。我实际上会引导大家去看美国政府问责局（GAO，政府问责局）最近发布的一份关于与组织监控相关的最佳实践的出色报告。我认为该报告中的一些建议非常出色，其他各个机构都可以采纳。因此，其他考虑工人安全的机构将是 OSHA、NIOSH、CDC，所有这些组织都在考虑工人安全，他们可以将有关监控的规则纳入他们已经在做的事情中，以确保人们在工作中的安全。你如何看待长期发展？我的意思是，这是会长期存在的事情，它会变得更好，还是会变得更加无处不在？我希望我能预知未来。我认为我们中的任何人都很难知道未来会带来什么。我认为在没有任何干预的情况下，我看到的是人们越来越像可以随时更换的可互换机器。我认为这是一个
There are. I will actually direct people to the GAO put out a great report, the government accountability office, just recently, about best practices related to organizational monitoring. And there are some recommendations in that report that I think are really excellent that various other agencies can adopt. So other agencies that think about worker safety would be OSHA, NIOSH, the CDC, all of these organizations. are thinking about work or safety, and they can incorporate rules about monitoring into what they already do to keep people safe at work. What do you see long term? I mean, is this something that is here to stay and will it get better, or is it just going to become even more pervasive? I wish I could see the future. I think it's hard for any of us to know what the future brings these days. I think in the absence of any intervention, what I see is people being treated more and more like interchangeable machine swapped out at a moment's notice. And I think that's a
非常消极的趋势。为了与自动化并肩工作，人们需要约束自己的行为。他们必须以可预测的方式行事，以便自动化知道该做什么。而这种监控本质上正在加速这一结果，这意味着人们的行为受到越来越多的约束，以至于他们变得更像机器，这样自动化才能理解他们、与他们合作并有可能取代他们。我认为很多公司都在指望这一点。他们都在押注这一点。我个人对“这项工作可以被自动化”或“这个任务可以被自动化”的说法持高度怀疑态度。我认为这表明他们严重缺乏对工作实际复杂性的理解。当人们试图将
really negative trend. In order to work alongside automation, people need to constrain their behavior. They have to behave in predictable ways so the automation knows what to do. And this surveillance is essentially accelerating that outcome to say that the people are having their behavior constrained more and more and more so that they are becoming more like machines so that the automation can understand them and work with them and potentially replace them. I think a lot of companies are counting on that. They're betting on that. I'm personally very skeptical about claims that this job can be automated or this task can be automated. I think it shows a real lack of understanding about how complex work really is. And people will start learning their lessons as they try to automate
事情自动化然后发现其后果时，他们就会开始吸取教训。但我认为我们将经历一个时期，在这个时期里，人们正在以惨痛的代价了解什么是可以自动化的，什么是不能自动化的。对于那些对被监视感到毛骨悚然的员工，你有什么建议吗？我的意思是，在 Zoom 或 Teams 会议期间，你应该关闭摄像头吗，或者不要把手机带进洗手间？我的意思是，为了试图保护哪怕一点点隐私，你应该做什么？是的，我认为意识到你的设备可以捕获关于你的什么信息非常重要。我认为很多人没有意识到他们的手机是一个监听设备，无论是否有任何应用程序被激活。它都在监听你。
things and then discover the consequences of that. But I think we'll have to go through a period where people are learning the hard way about what can and cannot be automated. Do you have any tips for employees who are basically creeped out by being watched? I mean, should you turn off the camera during Zoom or team meetings or don't carry your phone with you to the bathroom? I mean, what, you know, what should you do to try to protect some modicum of privacy? Yeah, I think being aware of what your devices can capture about you is really important. I think a lot of people don't appreciate that their cell phone is a listening device, whether it's any app is activated or not. It's listening to you.
它在记录你搜索的内容、你发电子邮件的对象、你站在谁附近、你在哪里、如果你是司机、你开得有多快。因此，了解你所知道的设备正在捕获什么信息非常重要。并确保你保持良好的界限，不要在办公室进行私人对话。我认为这已经是一个好习惯了。但鉴于墙壁随时可能在监听你，现在这变得更加重要。在会议期间保持摄像头关闭是一个有趣的建议，因为这也是一个会影响你同事的问题，对吧？所以这是一个应该在团队层面上进行讨论的问题，可能涉及团队层面的做法。但我认为这是一个可以与你的工作小组或经理发起的合理建议，可以说，我们可以共同采取哪些措施来建立更好的界限并限制存储的个人信息量？是什么让你对这个研究方向感兴趣？嗯，这很有趣。所以我在这个领域已经工作了很长时间。最初的几个项目是在培训的背景下进行的，即 surveillance 或 monitoring，
It's recording what you. you search, who you email, who you're standing near, where you are, if you're a driver, how fast you're going. So being aware of what information is being captured by devices that you are aware of is really important. And making sure that you practice good boundaries and you're not conducting personal conversations in the office. I think it's already a good habit. But it's even more important now, given that the walls could be listening to you at any moment. Keeping your cameras off during meetings is an interesting one because that's a, that's something that affects your coworkers too, right? So that's a conversation that should be
为了给它起一个更中性的名字，在培训研究中可能真的非常有价值，因为它可以为人们提供可以据此采取行动的即时反馈，而不是等到你犯了一堆错误之后，一周后人们才告诉你哪里做错了。它可能是一个私人教练。但从一开始，就存在一个问题，即这种反馈是有益的还是会分散注意力。从那时起，随着越来越多关于监控潜在危害的证据（比如在社会意义上）不断积累，问题的焦点真正发生了变化，变得更多地关乎后果，而不是这种个性化培训的微观背景。
happening at the team level, potentially about about team level practices. But I think that's a reasonable thing to initiate with your, with your work group or with your manager to say, what are some things we can do collectively to, to have better boundaries and limit the amount of personal information that's being stored. What got you interested in this line of research? Well, that's interesting. So I've been working on this for a very long time. And the first few projects were in the context of training, that surveillance or monitoring,
对于想要更多了解这种监控软件的听众，是谁在制作它？我的意思是，如果我想了解更多关于它的来源以及它可能被用于什么，我该如何找到它？有成千上万的供应商会向你出售设备来做这种追踪。有趣的是，该设备可能不是为此目的制造的，但一旦创建，你仍然可以将其用于该目的。有一个很好的例子，一种设备被创建为环境监测器，以便人们可以控制建筑物的气候控制系统，
to give it a more neutral name, could be potentially really valuable in training research because it's giving people instant feedback that they can act on instead of waiting until you make a bunch of mistakes, and then a week later people tell you what you did wrong. It can be a personal coach potentially. But from the beginning, there was a question about whether this feedback would be beneficial or distracting. And from there, as more and more evidence accumulated about the potential harms of surveillance, like in a societal sense, then the focus of the question really changed to be more about the consequences and not about this sort of might. micro context of personalized training.
比如无论谁回家，你都可以在白天调低空调。因此，它的初衷是非常具有亲社会性的，但有些人发现你可以利用这些信息来决定或确定谁在办公室待到很晚，谁早退了。因此，一旦数据在那里，你就可以从中做出各种其他推论。所以任何设备都可以用于此目的。还有许许多多专门为此目的出售设备的供应商。它们可能作为仪表盘进行营销，例如。因此，医院可能会被出售一个仪表盘，以便他们能够更有效地监控其人员的动向，更快地将人员部署到紧急情况中。它不会被称为间谍软件，对吧？但它仍然可以用于
For listeners who want to know more about this kind of surveillance software, who's making it? I mean, how would I find out more about it if I wanted to know where it's coming from and what potentially might be used for? There are just thousands and thousands of vendors who will sell you devices to do this kind of tracking. What's interesting is that the device might not be manufactured for that purpose, but you can still use it for that once it's created. And there's a great example of a device that was created to be an environmental monitor so that people could control the climate control at a building,
那个目的。那么你现在正在关注哪些问题？你目前有一些研究正在进行，或者你正在计划一些将要探讨的事情吗？是的，所以我想我们最近对两件事真的很感兴趣。一个是人们在拥有安全、有保障的工作与没有保障的工作时所经历的不同影响。在美国，越来越多的工作是我们所说的不稳定工作。也许它们不是全职的。也许它们不提供福利。它们没有加入工会。你的时间表每周都不是可预测的。你的工作听起来越是这样，你真正站出来反对雇主虐待的权力就越少。因此，我们仍然对在技术监控的背景下这种情况如何变得更糟非常感兴趣。
like whatever went home, you could turn down the air conditioning for the day. So it had a really very pro-social intent, but some people figured out that you could use that information to decide or to determine who was staying late at the office, who was sneaking out early. And so that once the data there, you can make all kinds of other inferences from it. So any device can be used for this. There are also lots and lots of vendors who will sell devices specifically for this purpose. And they might be marketed as dashboards, for example. So a hospital might be sold a dashboard so they can monitor the movements of their personnel more efficiently, deploy somebody more quickly to an emergency. It's not going to be called spyware, right? But it still can be used for
另一个我认为非常重要的问题是我们之前稍微讨论过的分心问题，即当人们的注意力从他们应该做的事情转移到自我监控以及确保自己在镜头前表现正确上时，他们身上发生了什么。发生的情况是，你总是处于舞台上，对吧？你总是有点在考虑自己是如何被感知的，并确保自己表现出正确的形象或正确的行为。这非常累人。我们知道人们不可能整天都在这样做而不会精疲力竭。由于总是处于舞台上，我们看到了大量精疲力竭的现象。根据我们所谈论的工作类型，
that purpose. So what are the questions you're looking at now? Do you have some research going at the moment or the things that you're planning that you're going to be asking about? Yeah, so I think we're really interested lately in two things. One is the different effects that people experience when they have a secure, safe job versus not. More and more people in the United States have jobs that we would call precarious. Maybe they're not full-time. Maybe they don't offer benefits. They're not unionized. Your schedule is not predictable from week to week. The more your job sounds like that, the less power you really have to stand up for yourself to employer mistreatment. And so we're really interested still in how that can be made even worse in the context of technological
这可能会非常非常危险。我之前提到过警察，想想空中交通管制员。当你做这些类型的工作时，你需要休息。有没有一些工作是监控没有发生并且你认为不会发生的？例如，你是一位学者。老大哥在看着你吗？我想是的，可能吧，确实有，而且这样做有充分的理由。有充分的理由确保我没有给学生发电子邮件并对他们大喊大叫，或者作为一名公共雇员，我们的电子邮件通信是可以根据信息自由法（FOIA）被索取的，因此在某种程度上，有些追踪在某些情况下就像是相当深入的追踪。但此时此刻我身上没有摄像头，除了我们用于这个播客的这个摄像头。
surveillance. And the other area that I think is really important is the issue of distraction that we talked about a little bit already, that what's happening to people when their attention is being taken away from what they should be doing towards sort of self-monitoring and making sure that you're acting correctly on camera. What happens is that you're just always on stage, right? You're always thinking a little bit about how you're being perceived and making sure that you're putting forward the right image or the right behavior. And that's very taxing. We know that people can't keep that up all day every day without burning out. And we're seeing lots and lots of burnout as a result of being always on stage. Depending on the kind of job we're talking about,
我认为总会有某种程度的追踪，因为出于责任和可能出现的此类问题的考虑，对追踪和数据保存的需求不断增加。因此，我没有信心说存在一个不被监控的职业，除非你是自谋职业，住在乡下，而且你知道的，
that can be really, really dangerous. Police officers, I mentioned already, think of air traffic controllers. You need to take breaks when you do these kinds of jobs. Are there jobs where surveillance isn't happening and you think won't happen? For example, you're an academician. Is a big brother watching you? I think yes probably so there are and there are good reasons to do so there are good reasons to make sure I am not emailing students and yelling at them or as a public employee our email communication is requestable by FOIA and so in that way like there are there is quite some tracking that is in some cases like quite quite intensive but there's no cameras on me right now except for this camera
你不需要对任何人负责，那么也许你没有被追踪。哦，好吧，巴伦博士，这不是一个以最快乐的基调结束的访谈，但我要感谢你今天加入我们。这真的非常有趣。很抱歉我成了一个扫兴的人。你可以在我们的网站 speakingofpsychology 上找到《心理学谈话》以前的节目。或者在 Apple、Spotify、YouTube 或你获取播客的任何地方收听。如果你喜欢你听到的内容，请订阅并留下评价。如果你对未来的播客有评论或想法，你也可以给我们发电子邮件，邮箱是 Speaking of Psychology at AP。
that we're using for the podcast. I think there will always be some level of that because there's an increasing need to do tracking and data keeping for liability and for those kinds of issues that might come up. So I'm not really confident saying that there's an occupation that is not monitored unless you are self-employed and you live out in the countryside and you know,
www.org。《心理学谈话》由李·维纳曼（Lee Weinerman）制作。感谢收听，我是代表美国心理学协会的金·米尔斯。本集暂无评论。点击转录中的任意句子即可发表评论。
you're accountable to nobody, then maybe you're not tracked. Oh, well, Dr. Barron, it wasn't the happiest note to end up, but I want to thank you for joining me today. This has been really interesting. Sorry to be a bummer. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at speakingofpsychology. Or on Apple, Spotify, YouTube, or wherever you get your podcasts. And if you like what you've heard, please subscribe and leave a review. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can also email us at Speaking of Psychology at AP.
如果你不对任何人负责，那么也许你就不会被追踪。好的，巴伦博士，虽然这不是一个最快乐的结束语，但我要感谢你今天能来参加我们的节目。这真的非常有趣。抱歉给您带来压抑的感觉。您可以在我们的网站 speakingofpsychology.org 上收听《心理学热线》的往期节目，也可以在 Apple、Spotify、YouTube 或其他任何您收听播客的平台上找到我们。如果您喜欢我们的节目，请订阅并留下评价。如果您对未来的播客有任何意见或想法，也可以通过电子邮件联系我们：Speaking of Psychology 邮箱...
www.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Weinerman. Thank you for listening for the American Psychological Association. I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
...网址为 apa.org。《心理学热线》由李·维纳曼（Lee Weinerman）制作。感谢收听，我是美国心理学会的金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。